what do you want to do buddy
who the wants to do that dog what's
your ethnicity oh this guy man forgot
where he came from literally what do you
actually do you just love snitching on
everybody huh
dreaming light just snitching snitching
snitching you just look at how brown
people one way or the other
listen making America great again are
you in a relationship what is your
girl's ethnicity
ah there it is you had enough of this
chunk yeah anytime he's nagging him he
could just flash his badge in her face
and be like who doesn't take out the
trash enough I think I take out the
trash for a living actually if you think
about it haha